olá pessoal de quem falou da crise muito
menos a mais um vídeo e precisa muito
nesta noite pessoal estou eu e dani
sozinho em casa porque normalmente da
equipe e triste mas pessoal quero nem
saber i nós vamos testar uma aplicação
que eu encontrei para o iphone clube
tricolor alegou lei só é basicamente uma
aplicação que detecta se a fantasmas ou
não em casa é só nós apontávamos a
câmera eo vai detectar que já encontrou
um fantasma que é isso o radar e
supostamente fantasma está mais à
esquerda está pura que toque a seu
bairro coke tem 136 anos de idade e um
espeto o movimento que isto é tudo falso
a aplicação não funciona uma brincadeira
ok mas vamos entrar aqui na brincadeira
e vamos ver o que é que nós conseguimos
encontrar aqui em casa o espectro agora
está em um quadro não vou te matar que
eu tô vendo posso fazer uma pergunta do
sim ou não eu posso responder então
vamos fazer a pergunta tu és um espectro
bom
op é um espectro maléfico
acho que ele ainda está aqui só eu mas
como podem ver eu consegui filmar a casa
inteira
isto é muito assustador porque naquela
ambiência assim encaixes roupa e conta
que outro time continuou sem grandes 683
é no hu o que é muito velha quase
mantida
tu és um espírito bom ou mau eu só jesus
esta aplicação tem várias outras coisas
tem aqui sensibilidade e também aqui mf
que eu acho que a maneira como nós
tentamos comunicar com os fantasmas
através do som embora lá andar pela casa
e só vamos tentar descobrir que tipo de
moniz aqui em casa espiritual que for
urna tem outra que 24 anos esperei que
vem devo este é vingativo tentar com
cômica do que este vingar de alguém que
já esteve aqui em casa
sim o devedor piada não é ser eu sei que
isto é tudo brincadeira mas está muito
porque dá pra comunicar com deus 993
anos
eu mal ao meio ambiente sei lá é uma
alma que é muito conhece o espírito
anterior
por isso é tão antigo que nem se deu com
o espírito 24 anos acabou por preço alvo
em itaqui 256 anos disse patriota em eu
quero tomar é o qual quer se vingar de
mim não querem dar minhocas sei lá como
aqui algum espírito o nosso estoque está
mas está muito atrás ainda mais vídeos
deste gênero onde o texto assim é este
tipo de aplicações permitem bastante
muito lá e inscreva se não forem
inscritos para continuar a nossa
instituição de caça fantasmas encontrei
aqui outro falta mesmo é que já é neste
quadro que tem 198 anos é um espectro de
comunicar com ela é verdade que o
estádio dentro desse quadro aprisionava
então volta pra casa pra quem faz o quê
fazer é de licença tagliassuchi não era
uma pergunta vou trabalhar só comentei
embaixo também perguntas que terão que
eu faço
lembre-se que estamos mortos você ou
mandou uma mensagem aos jovens por silva
deve ter um leitor cara eu vou pegar uma
foto
a lei está mesmo acima de 35 anos
inscrito vingativo é verdade que tu quer
possuir o dante futuro não é isso tudo
eu quero encontrar um espírito que se
relacione com um body cali porque quer
saber se eu estava possuído não ok então
vamos vamos parar até para ser outro o
que o acordou nesta aplicação é muito
sinistro
um sinistro ok vamos passá-lo pessoal
estamos mostrando a aplicação aqui o tu
tá mesmo aceitar mas não me abandone
qualquer tem 50 anos é um fantasma a eu
acho que é o mesmo todos todos eu disse
todos não sei acho que uma pessoa já
viveu aqui alguém chamado toby este
viaduto está na parede chama-se todo o
rs foi tempo 100% vai ter o mesmo e aí
já temos um nome a seguir à outra vez
vamos tentar encontrar aqui algum
espírito que nos dê algumas respostas
sobre todos aqui dentro da equipe
236 anos são aspectos sabe alguma
informação sobre todo mundo sabe mas já
tentar se interagir com o todo obtivesse
alguma resposta do todo
então o todo existiu um toque está
presente mas o todo não fala galera só
um objeto estamos pensando que ela é o
mesmo enviado então falar com ele mas eu
já poderia assinar vamos tentar
encontrar o outro fantasma que nos dê
respostas aqui
armário eu tinha uma vida aqui é verdade
que já bem visto aqui eu estou aqui só
apesar de ser uma brincadeira estava de
certo que vamos aproximar do espírito
tentar falar melhor conjunto mil deles
já tivesse alguma relação com o todo
ninguém está com tobi já tem pasto
comunicar com todo obteve esta alguma
resposta
ok então eu tenho resposta ou seja eu
não se relacionava com elton tentou
comunicar com ele e teve uma resposta o
que eu disse era algo bom
o totti está possuído quanto marca de
maranello de barra eu tomar fiaram
naquele dia naquela que sabe mais
qualquer coisa que nos possa dizer sobre
o top
não sabe mais nada tem 52 anos já viu
aqui museu e que estava coisas sobre o
todo que está fracassando
então vamos lá tentar encontrar outro
fantasma porque isso aqui já depp já o
prudente também low calma 6 183 anos
alfa que lhes falte chamas de ralf ao
futuro o que está aqui em casa
ok rápido jovem vai ficar em casa
certamente que sim porque senão eu não
tava quem não viveu o que vocês um homem
ralf viajará a visitar alguém o exame da
ordem que esteja aqui então esse teu
amigo que teve esta visita já morreu
então é outro fantasma ok esse teu amigo
é outro fantasma que está cá em casa
ok então pode ser um fantasma não está
aqui em casa e seu amigo é um fantasma
ok eu vai tentar encontrar um nome que o
fantasma aqui mas já não está aqui então
eu ando aqui para servir se encontra vai
sair desta casa ainda hoje eu tenho que
saber né
[Música]
eu quero perguntar só que aí então vai
te embora eu expulso desta casa eu só
saio daqui pra você
ok eu sei vamos ver se podemos o sinal
de que casas vão para a janela entrou
pela janela 7 138 anos almejando vamos
provar o que eu tenho que fazer é
verdade que entrar pela janela um
espírito bom então um expulso desta casa
pelo mesmo sítio entrado pela janela
eu sou forte sou bom a espantar o
fantasma pelo visto foi embora
eu falo ainda está lá ainda antes da
hora eu voltar bem e até mesmo ir embora
o show fala eu tô super uma parede tanto
esteve lá o meu consumo é só vocês viram
eu mandei embora em lentamente do sul
pela parede campeonato fora e podemos o
sinal que eu voltei para trazer a uma
aplicação do telemóvel
ela estava em andamento mas que está
muito real eu estou me responder como eu
imaginei que eu vou responder
e eu sei pelo cinema dentro visto alguém
que está em liberdade e os ursos panda
demônios encontrei outro sua última
ontem o trocou o genoa 3843 anos
aumentando mesmo não é não existem mais
iraque venceu por wo já expulsaram nem
fui perguntar nada fácil desta casa é
agora pede eles é sinal de mau gosto no
teto não fique é só de agora comida
estragada temos algumas fora do brasil
isso ficará em casa mas primeiro jogo
fora do prazo vai embora
o pessoal tá feita a nossa são de
espírito bom e só espero que vocês
tenham gostado aqui desta aplicação
claro que tudo uma brincadeira claro que
isso não funciona ou será que funciona
eu não sei baixo em vocês aí testa em
brincar em casa e só para quem está aqui
o vídeo já sabendo ser muito lexon
frente que tinha no canal inscrevam 6
fiquem bem espero ter mais filhos do
casal um filho ambiental